résultat du scrutin votant 345 exprimé
307 pour 193 contre 114 de Sénat a
adopté
[Musique]
un compromis trouvé entre les exigences
du sénattre et c'est le fruit de cette
réflexion qui a fait en sorte que nous
puissions je pense voter sans état d'âme
cette réforme qui a été particulièrement
adouci par rapport aux mesures proposées
directement par le gouvernement et qui
fait que nous avons pris en compte les
difficultés notamment exprimées à
travers l'usure professionnelle nous y
sommes attachés
[Musique]
s'agit de travailler progressivement
plus pour équilibrer notre système de
retraite il s'agissait aussi de fermer
les principaux régimes spéciaux dans le
respect de la clause dite du grand-père
s'assurer aussi d'augmenter la retraite
minimale pour une carrière complète
on nous dit la CMP d'hier
à Platon obligé nous avons contraint à
aller sur tous les articles mais tout
était bouclé hier matin tout était
bouclé dans l'intérêt du gouvernement et
du président de la République ma
conclusion comment allez-vous réparer ce
pays que vous êtes en train durablement
de fracturer
[Musique]